alors fatou est ce que tu veux poser
on savait qu'un coup de coeur alors
c'est même pas un coup de coeur c'est un
coup d'amour c'est un coup d'amour pour
la personne que j'adule de plus en ce
moment j'ai nommé n golo kanté alors la
donne mais il est aimé par tout le monde
en fait c'est un grand monsieur il est
toujours humble et toujours discret il
c'est devenu l'une des clauses des
coqueluches française voulait pousser il
a fait quelque chose d'extraordinaire
récemment en fait ça me dit il devait
prendre un train pour paris il a loupé
et ça il a retrouvé des fans qui l'ont
reconnue dans la rue et qu'est ce qu'il
a fait au lieu de prendre une photo et
c'est tout il les a rejoint chez eux et
il a fait des matches à halle sur la
console il a mangé avec eux du rif et de
laisser les fans
il a été chez les fans directement pensé
c'est incroyable et bravo à ngolo
déclaré
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste de jouer un match
intéressant puisque les militaires
interdisent contre cardiff 80 il avait
gagné il a raté le train ils étalaient
la mosquée et c'est là qu'il a rencontré
des gens qui ont exactement il ya un
train non l'eurostar et produits chez
les gens là que tu dis mais je vous
renvoie des images à bombay
les
[Applaudissements]
j'essaie de proximité des bleus avec le
public lassé en angleterre mais avec
tous les publics qui fait qu'ils sont
ultra populaire aujourd'hui vous
souvenez à un moment on disait l'équipe
de france est une rupture avec le public
euh non seulement y gagne en plus sont
sympas voilà c'est merveilleux m